l armée partager mon bonheur
[Musique]
merci de nous accueillir un fait
tellement plaisir
vous parlez souvent de votre part marcel
martel ouais il m'a vraiment frappé
lorsque je suis je suis rentré dans
votre maison
c'est cette voie votre coin familial
selon les parents de mes parents votre
main votre père le grand père attaché à
l'histoire de votre famille sur musquin
dans votre famille l'histoire musicale
oui parce que moi j'étais 13 je vais
énormément d'admiration pour mon père
depuis que j'étais tout petit je
trouvais que c'était une mère chanteurs
que je n'avais jamais entendu et encore
aujourd'hui je trouve que mon père avait
une voix magnifique
il écrivait des chansons super
[Musique]
j'ai la chance d'être la fille d'un des
plus grands pionniers et est donc je
pense que cette musique là meurent parce
que ces gens-là écrivait tellement des
belles chansons sont encore vivantes
aujourd'hui on va vous rendre hommage à
drummondville pour la grande première de
dubaï
c'est un film sur les années guy dans ce
documentaire on vous entend dire que
vous vouliez petit pas nécessairement
faire une carrière en musique mais ce
que c'est votre père qui voudrait c'est
vrai son expérience c'est vrai parce que
moi je croyais pas en moins alors c'est
mon père qui croyait beaucoup beaucoup
en moi
moi je me voyais pas dans la gloire et
je t'ai bien avec mon père je détourne
et puis c'était parfait pour moi
et puis qu'un comme de raison vermont
perdent poucet parce qu'ils voyaient ce
que moi je n'avais pas vu j'imagine
[Musique]
en fait quand même pas mal parce qu'à
carrière vous avez vendu 10 millions
disent ouais super rebelle
ce beaucoup d'années pour quelqu'un qui
voulait pas devenir chanteur s'est quand
même aux papilles papé ou épopée
[Musique]
mais votre premier succès ça et puis mes
propos oui oui comment vous expliquez
que ça aussi de bien fonctionner cette
chanson l'appui que vous avez votre
interprétation est tellement que
l'original fondre au bain oui je me
souviens de l'original puis c'est drôle
parce que j'avais entendu - l'original
du certaines de mes chansons préférées
et je trouvais ça tellement bon cette
chanson alors quand j'ai eu mon doigt me
le fais écouter jésus ben je la connais
je laime à 6 cette chanson l'ops à ces
semaines après j'ai très beau studio et
12 semaines plus tard vous êtes une méga
star wars ça s'est passé à peu près
comme ça et puis mais c'est arrivé
tellement vite que ça a étourdi c'est
sûr que ça a été redit mais
la balle est parti puis ben finalement
le reste assez de l'histoire
[Musique]
et
après
marquez nous avait inquiété ces
dernières années parce que vous êtes en
rémission d'un cancer
oui alors tout naturellement comment va
la santé la santé va de mieux en mieux
c'est sûr que je je je je pense pas
récupérer mes énergies à 100% mais
ça va beaucoup mieux ça a été
extrêmement difficile mais ça va mieux
pied chaufferie jeu ça vient de là oui
je ne sais quand moi j'ai toujours eu
les cheveux droit et quand ça c'est mais
repoussée parce que bien entendu j'ai
perdu mes cheveux en saas et mère pour
6,7 à friser comme ça et je me disais
qu'est ce que je vais faire avec ça
alors je fais avec
c'est tout alors pour vous qu'est ce qui
s'en vient du nouvel album des concerts
en 2021 2020 qu'est ce qui s'en vient
c'est un album avec paul neige et après
ça quand le temps le voudra qu'on soit
tout le monde en forme
on va faire une tournée ça va
probablement être ma dernière
mais bon ce soir la dernière c'est tout
mais on va faire un tour n'est figé à
j'ai hâte parce que j'ai été levée sur
scène et ça me manque
renée martel merci merci
morcellement du soir
[Applaudissements]